when you buy a home in the US there is a
basic promise that home values will go
up over time and that is what you're
seeing on this chart let's adjust it for
inflation okay jerky or but still
basically goes up The Story Goes Like
This Money by itself loses value over
time that's inflation but if you own
your home in the US you own an asset
that is appreciating in value by bu it
probably required you to save a bunch of
money and also borrow a lot of money
which you need to pay back over time as
opposed to renting your home which
basically just requires rent but now you
own it it could be collateral if you
ever need money like to start a business
or to send your kids to college one day
you might sell it for more than you
bought it but also stability peace of
mind so that you may maintain your place
in society you get it if we look at the
middle 60% of the US population in terms
of wealth the middle class the bulk of
the wealth held by that group is made up
of the homes they live in it's a big
part of why we think of home ownership
as the ticket to financial stability in
the US to securing and then building
your own wealth but the barriers to
buying a home in the US are getting
higher so how much higher exactly and if
you can't buy a home what does that mean
for your
future
[Music]
so first let's go back to the median US
housing price over the past 50 years up
to
2022 now add income onto it yeah median
wages have not kept pace with the
increase in the cost of housing this is
Michelle Dickerson she studies why it's
become so hard for lower income and
middle inome people to be come and
remain middle class now let's go back
about 50 years and look at a couple
whose household income is exactly the
national us median at that time in 1972
money about
$10,000 imagine right they want to buy a
house the median us home price at that
time was about
$29,000 that is about three times their
income before the 1980s it was possible
for a young person to graduate from high
school find a job that was a fulltime
40-hour a week job with benefits that
paid them enough for them to be able to
buy a home now let's go 50 years forward
and run those numbers for 2022 median
income median home price this house is
more than six times this household's
income so that is what we're looking at
when we go back to that chart of income
and housing prices again adjusted for
inflation and compare this Gap to this
Gap now as for the home prices
themselves let's zoom in to make that
data easier to see bring it up to date
you can see that the prices are starting
to go down a little bit in 2023 but part
of why they got so high in the first
place is a lack of Supply this chart
shows What's called the homeowner
vacancy rate over about 70 years it's
the percent of homes in the US that are
actually for sale and it's currently the
lowest since we started collecting data
and that is partly the result of
restrictive zoning laws locally set
rules all across the US that regulate
things like where homes can and can't be
built how many units a building can have
in it and how densely housing can be
built it leads to fewer homes getting
built which leads to fewer homes to buy
now as for the homes that are for sale
that's what we're looking at here this
chart splits all homes on the market in
the US into tiers by price so these are
the lower cost homes and these are the
higher cost homes and it tracks over
time what percentage of the market each
tier represents you can see that over
the past few years homes that cost less
than $200,000 have made up less and less
of what's available and homes above half
a million or even a million dollars are
representing a greater and greater share
of what's for sale so housing in the US
is scarce and it's expensive but we're
actually missing a really important
piece of the story here we'll talk about
that after this quick
message student loans can really make
you sweat only one in three students
understand the financial terms of their
loans and nearly half of federal student
loan borrowers don't know how much they
owe or who they owe it to so how can
borrowers go from confused to
confident it might sound obvious but
research shows a strong connection
between financial literacy and
successful student debt management so
let's build out a financial literacy
toolkit first thing to consider is the
numbers find out how much you owe and
what your interest rate is prioritize
paying off the loans with the highest
interest rate first second is to learn
the terminology this helps you
understand what your options are for
example auto debit is when you set up
automatic monthly payments which may
reduce your interest rate by 0.25% bonus
tip call your lender and see if you can
have your payments go directly towards
your principle which is the amount of
money you borrowed so you can pay off
your loans faster look into refinancing
that's combining loans into one with a
new lender potentially also getting a
lower interest rate find out if you
qualify for student loan forgiveness
that that way you can have some or all
of your Federal loans lifted and the
last thing in the toolkit making the
plan follow through on the approach that
works for you maybe you qualify for the
save plan or maybe you can make even
higher monthly payments to prevent more
interest from
acre make a plan that fits within your
financial goals by understanding your
student loans you can take charge of
them learn more at secret.com money
moves okay let's revisit the two parts
of a home purchase first you pay some
percentage of the cost of the home UPF
front maybe 5% maybe 20% the down
payment the rest of the money you will
need to borrow this is the mortgage
you'll pay that back in monthly payments
but the size of those payments can vary
a lot depending on the interest rate of
the loan this chart shows the average
interest rate of a common type of
mortgage over the past 50 years in the
long term it's mostly been going down a
lower mortgage interest rate means lower
monthly payments so while this chart of
housing prices told a story of it
getting harder to buy a house over time
the interest rate chart seems to tell a
different story of very high and
burdensome interest rates at one point
and mostly lower and lower interest
rates over time so now the story is
slightly more complicated and if we look
at them on the same timeline they seem
to kind of go in opposite directions
until they don't let's just look at the
recent past in 2020 a pandemic was
happening and lots of people suddenly
wanted to move and home prices started
to shoot up in 2022 as the US Government
tried to slow down inflation interest
rates began to shoot up and now they're
both still pretty high not only that
because a lot of current homeowners have
mortgage interest rates down in this
range the 3 4 5% Zone it means that
since selling their home might mean
having to buy a new one at an interest
rate up here fewer people are selling
their homes it helps keep this that
homeowner vacancy rate low and it keeps
home prices High by the way all these
barriers to home buying are exacerbated
for people of color who are more likely
to be denied mortgage loans regardless
of income the website Zillow looks at
several of the factors we've talked
about including home prices income
mortgage rates and it calculates the
monthly burden on the average new
homeowner according to them that burden
is close to the highest on record
[Music]
there are lots more factors at play here
but overall especially if you're a young
person in the US it is natural to feel
discouraged by the housing market and
the question then becomes can you still
somehow have this without this can you
find some kind of financial stability
even if you continue to rent where you
live well let's start with the obvious
this is not even always going up just
for one example this is the 2008 housing
crisis which was a disaster for home
values now they've obviously gone way
back up but we can look at other kinds
of investment over that time period too
here's a common stock market index it
also went down and then up now that is
an extremely imprecise comparison
between two very different ways to
invest but you could also chart several
kinds of investment this way and they
would all go up sometimes down sometimes
hopefully up in the long term but in the
short term you do not ever know what is
coming next a home is a pretty unique
kind of purchase it's a necessity that
you buy at Great cost but if you look at
it as a long-term investment it's not
actually that special if you want the
stable investment you go out and invest
in a nice you know Government Bond
mutual fund you don't have to worry
about that is most likely you know going
to go up and if it doesn't go up this
month over time it will one thing charts
like this show is that the conditions
for buying a home change recently
they've been kind of bad they might not
always be
but if you're looking for long-term
Investments to grow your wealth even if
you rent your home a house is not your
only
[Music]
option